déjà est ce que vous pouvez me rappeler
votre nom et votre prénom
jal de gros et okc et quel est votre
entreprise on entreprit ici de christine
broderie je fais de la de la brûlerie
surtout textile depuis comme il a été
créé votre entreprise
depuis décembre 2012 ok et qu'est ce que
vous a permis la victoire en fait au
challenge et créateurs je pense que
c'est mon courage de
dans l'insertion pas seulement parfois
pas été très facile et donc étant donné
que je suis toute seule avec avec des
enfants dont un handicapé donc ça n'a
pas été vraiment face et voilà et la
victoire au challenge et créateurs si
vous apportez quoi concrètement
ben de la publicité sur tout et puis le
fait d'avoir une récompense aussi ça
aide beaucoup pour acheter du matériel
complémentaire
ok si vous aviez si vous deviez retenir
une qualité qu'il faut pour créer son
entreprise laquelle vous donneriez
alors si la persévérance
ok beau pas très bien c'est tout pour
moi versée